well here's quite a mystery the governor
of the largest state in america has gone
missing not seen since he had his covet
19 booster probably totally unrelated
been about 12 days now fox's bill
malugion is on the case for us tonight
hey bill
hey tucker good evening to you that's
right look california governor gavin
newsom has been m.i.a now for 11
straight days he has made zero public
appearances since late october and
really nobody knows where he's at or
what he's been up to take a look at this
video right here this was the very last
time newsome was seen in public back on
october 27th you see him flexing there
this is right after he got his covet 19
booster shot in oakland at the time he
said it was painless he posed for the
cameras again flexing in that t-shirt
again and he also urged others to get
their booster shots as well well just a
couple of days after that on october
29th newsome's office very abruptly
announced the governor was canceling a
planned trip to participate in the
united nations climate summit his office
cited unspecified family obligations now
newsom's office went on to say the
governor would attend that conference
virtually but to this day he still has
not appeared in that conference now
since then governor newsom has only
appeared in pre-recorded video
statements and in family halloween
photos you can see he posted the day
after halloween
uh he showed an instagram photo of his
parent or of his family all of them
dressed up as pirates and then on sunday
yesterday his wife posted this on
twitter take a look at this tweet right
here she wrote quote it's funny how
certain folks can't handle the truth
when someone cancels something maybe
they're just in the office working maybe
in their free time they're at home with
their family at their kids sports
matches or dining out with their wife
please stop hating and get a life well
she deleted that tweet just a few
minutes after she posted it and tucker
governor newsom's office has refused to
clarify to the media exactly what family
obligations have been keeping him out of
the public eye however his press
secretary did confirm to fox news late
this afternoon that he will resume
public appearances sometime this week
that spokesman also went on to say that
his absence has had nothing to do
whatsoever with this coveted booster
shot send it back to you
bill molution great to see you tonight
you too
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else